hey welcome to big boot
i'm thinking i'm making limo
yeah that's it yeah that's it that's my
intro
she was she was bitching at me for like
not starting she was like you should
just go ahead and start start
the episode jess she's like well you
started okay
i'm just we have a guest today though
i'm being very very rude we have a guest
today we have nick yeah i don't know
your last name done
i'm the worst nick well i'm done
yeah yeah yeah thank you for having me
guys yeah yeah yeah
it's like a real set this is like you
guys got lights in here yeah kind of
this is dope this is really cool how
does it feel to be in a room full of
girls because it feels cool most of the
audience sees you with like a bunch of
dude like the jk dudes yeah like we just
grow out all the time so he's nice it's
a nice change of pace
yeah yeah you were saying that you grew
up with nothing but sisters
yeah i grew up with mostly sisters and
you know how many sisters
i have two sisters okay and then it
would always just be like
my sisters and i and my mom so i pretty
much had like three months are they
older
yes six and seven years apart i think
dudes that get raised by
older women they like understand women
better yeah you know what because they
just talk [ __ ] all the time yeah and
then i'm like all right
so you got used to it yeah i got used to
it i was like all right like whatever
you used to pms
you get used to like all that yeah it's
weird yeah and then now now that i'm
like with my lady
and i we're living with each other
there's just certain things that
like my tendencies are that she's just
like that she kind of doesn't really
understand
yeah or like she she goes like why do
you do that and i was like well
and i'll think back to when i was a kid
and i was like oh it's from
like little things i did as a kid like
what like this is [ __ ] weird but
whenever my mom she'd always be yelling
at us
all the time she'd be yelling all the
time but especially when she was
cleaning
the house and cleaning the dishes and
stuff like people existing while i'm
trying to clean
yeah yeah exactly would she be yelling
bro like all the time
and then sometimes like when my wife is
cleaning stuff at the house
i'll just think she's mad at me for some
reason [ __ ] weird right
you're just always guilty while somebody
yeah and i'm like hey you need help like
can i help you with something i was like
i was like wait like
she's not mad she goes no i'm fine and
she gets annoyed like leave me alone
like now i'm mad i was like yeah yeah
yeah right like it's
a double-edged sword so it's [ __ ]
weird it's like little things like that
that i'm starting to realize as i get
older i was like
oh i think it's because of this and i'm
able to like think about when i was a
kid
yeah and i could pinpoint exactly where
it comes from that's great you have that
awareness
yeah and also like your it sounds like
the way that you were raised and made
you
to be very empathetic towards whatever
like the other women are going through
because you're saying
cause you're saying like oh [ __ ] she
might be mad at me let me go ask if she
needs help let me
prevent the anger yeah or it's just
[ __ ] some weird trauma
that's another word i'm learning like oh
[ __ ] there's a thing called trauma
and things like you just like it's not
like in the big scheme of things but
like you know like more lower level like
yeah
where you just realize like oh that's
probably the reason why i act like that
or i
react a certain way or feel certain ways
because of like
stuff that happened when you were a kid
isn't that crazy like almost everything
like every trigger that you have is
something that happened in your first
six years of childhood you're just a
sponge absorbing the world and like
whatever
version of the world you got like that
got imprinted forever
and then like that's what you live your
life by yeah kind of up until you're
really
consciously yeah and and then you're
like wait what the [ __ ] is going on have
you ever done therapy or how do you feel
about
nah i'm down for it um you feel like
because you seem like a pretty like
you're level-headed you're doing your
thing
successful enough you know like so do
you think that even
still just being like a normal dude like
therapy could be helpful no i think
me and my wife talk about all the time
because she's in therapy and she talks
about how much it helps her and stuff
like that
and i i would see it i would see the
change and i was like yo [ __ ] maybe i
should get some
therapy or some [ __ ] it just helps
because i'm honest at a different angle
definitely i like that i like when other
people kind of say like they kind of
peek their head in and they'll tell me
like a different point of view i think
that's important
100 um but it's funny when
like i see changes in my wife because of
she's done therapy or how she kind of
looks at things
i think that's the biggest factor right
it's like looking from a different point
of view
super important and i tell her i'm like
[ __ ] now that i'm i have her health
insurance now so
okay okay now i got married
you know i don't even know hmo or ppo
means but i'm one of those
and uh i think you want a ppo so you
should check yeah i'll check i'll check
i'll
what does your wife do how long have you
been married give it give it
she is a clinical social worker oh no
for a hospital in the l.a area that
sounds like a stressful job
what does that mean stressful
i don't know i feel like i feel like she
probably deals a lot of really stressful
patients
yo yeah so she she works at a hospital
and she just deals with day to day she
works on the inpatient side
so i've learned what that means is she
works in the hospital she goes to see
patients
versus the outpatient is when you talk
to patients that leave the hospital or
they don't have a surgery exactly yeah
and that she provides resources or kind
of help them navigate like complex
situations
oh okay that's crazy because i didn't
know half the [ __ ] that social workers
do yeah cause when i think
social worker i think the people that
check on foster kids or
snatch people's kids yeah yeah yeah like
that's what everyone says kid snatchers
no people people really look at me like
in a hospital like she's not just
kidding
i was like i think that's a crime you
know that's a code pink or some [ __ ]
that's a baby snatcher yeah it's a
maternity yup
her job is really tough like her job is
really hard and how long have you guys
been married though
we've been married we got married
september
2020. we did it we had a cold war
last year congrats but we've been
together
we'll be 12 years and j uh yeah
so long i gotta get my [ __ ] together
i need to have your wife sit in here and
let me know why she let you wait 12
years yeah
damn or 11 yeah no yeah we were
together in high school we met in like
high school
hi you married your high school
sweetheart crazy have you ever had sex
with your wife
kind yeah oh kind of she's like we're
each other's first
you know like we're each other's first
everything yo
what's up you had a break or something
no not even no no no
no i think she's one no no
yeah no it is she's my first ever being
one woman i know it's crazy right is
that crazy think about it you're like
that's insane my mind is blowing yeah do
you ever think about
like do you ever feel like you missed
out or yeah
really yeah is it because you're here
natural
like a little bit but but even yeah it's
like i mean i know you're cool if your
wife hears it i get you know yeah i mean
like literally
i put on everything i love like how come
well you know what it is it's just like
i live through my friends like i
see through my buddies like point of
views and what they go through and i'm
like
no thank you like the way me me and my
wife were talking about it and we were
talking about
um online dating right yeah that's not
great
no for sure for sure for sure but how we
completely miss that
like we have no point of view like we've
never had to go through that
we've never had to like swipe or
anything yeah like we've never had to
talk on tinder which we're very
to me i'm like that's pretty fortunate
yeah right because
i hear nothing but horror stories from
like my clients from my female friends
my male friends they're just like
it's crazy like we'll go on their [ __ ]
and like [ __ ] around you know i mean but
for the most part it's like plus i mean
if you've dated since high school
you guys have like built systems
together basically yeah like true
you built your adult life together
that's it's so crazy so it's like i
always also kind of don't know
yeah what it what else it would be like
do you feel a little bit of codependency
because of that
because like if i only knew that
as my entire adult life without that
person i would be like i don't know
like part of your identity is yeah yeah
kind of like we're
co-dependent on a lot of things right
but for the most part like we kind of
always had our own lives which was
really cool
okay so like while she was going to
college i was at a completely different
school like we were
we were kind of living and doing her own
thing but i don't know
we just got lucky bro like we literally
got so lucky what's her schedule like
because
it sounds like if you work at a hospital
yeah she works she works like a 410
schedule so four days
10 hours my gosh and then my schedule is
kind of just
all over the place so it's like really
dependent on like if i see clients or
which by the way just for the viewers
that don't know what you do oh i'm a
personal trainer okay i work with people
online and slowly back in person and
stuff like that
so i work with like fighting yeah so
like in person a lot of times we do like
kickboxing boxing stuff but also we do
personal training like lifting weights
and and then on the online side we do a
lot of nutrition
coaching and a lot of uh like online
remote
uh programming stuff because those are
both very independent
careers for sure yeah yeah so it's just
something that i just kind of loved and
i just kind of got into and i just was
like this is what i do now so it's a lot
of fun it's dope it's cool
it's actually kind of crazy to think
back like we kind of were able to live
our own lives
separately but together at the same time
so i think that is a big reason yeah for
sure it is
because she's always like i gotta do
this yeah i'm doing my [ __ ] i'm like
cool i'm doing this so
we would kind of that alone time like
yeah like i think that's important
it's so important yeah because we're not
like oh we're we're just nick and tiff
like yeah exactly my wife's name is also
by the way which is crazy right i know
yeah
but pretty much it's like everyone knows
that we're together but
at the same time yeah like i'm not
afraid
you haven't lost your identity yeah like
she can hang out with my friends and
it's all good and i'm not there she's
actually doing that right now yeah
that's how i feel too
yeah yeah right it's great so it's it's
cool it's great like we i
yeah we just got really lucky man like
yeah yeah because that just blows my
mind like that you met a girl in high
school went ahead and married her and
then never really thought like
this this could have just been the high
school sweetheart maybe there was
something else
to i mean even especially as a man to
not think like
yeah that sow your seed mentality yeah
yeah
yeah you know just that did were you
dropped on your head or yeah
probably yeah you do a lot of like
kickboxing yeah yeah a lot of cd
is that brain trauma except it's like
you're having like
more stable behavior well you know the
cte which got kicked out
yeah yeah yeah like cool thank god yeah
like uh
i think we just communicate well you
know like i remember that's so key
yeah like seeing this is kind of well
thinking about how my parents grew up i
remember
always well how they were in a
relationship as i grew up
that's what i meant to say ct and um i
remember thinking i was like yo i don't
want to have this with my
significant other i remember thinking
that immediately like nah bro this is
this is not
it you know and um and then ever since
then i just would always think about
that and
like i would share that with my partner
and we would talk about that stuff and
she was like okay yeah i totally get
that and
obviously we we also had like some rough
times from here
but it was mostly mostly smooth just
because
i feel like her personality matches with
mine our values are
mostly in line i think that's really
important right so what part of high
school was it like middle high school or
like the end of high school we met like
our junior year we were friends for a
long time okay yeah you started dating
friends first really helps
yeah yeah yeah because you get to learn
each other without the commitment and
the romantic pressure
aspect to it and then you really can
decide like oh i actually like this
person
and it was crazy because we both before
we actually got together our senior year
we were both like kind of dating other
people right and
dude if i if she was my first girlfriend
oh bro this would have never worked out
like
it was just yeah it was a nightmare you
know and for her
she was dating some other dude at the
time and like
i think you just we kind of realized
like nah this ain't it
and then and then we started dating and
then it kind of just naturally
flowed together dude i relate so hard to
that yeah right exactly what happened
it's just like our relationship we had a
bad taste of something else
yeah and then you appreciate when you're
like with the person
and you're like oh this is different
because of x y and z
yeah yeah i have a question how come if
um
which it sounds like you guys have had a
really good relationship you've
been able to grow together and all that
stuff and
how what was it what changed in your
relationship
to for you guys to decide okay now let's
get married
well i think it was like our careers
were slowly starting to
you know yeah stabilized yeah and then
we started thinking of like it just it
was like a natural progression like all
right well we've been together for
around like 10 our 10-year anniversary
is when i proposed
wow yeah that was like 20 20. that was
january 22
wait no 2013 okay um yeah 2019
in january we've we proposed no we
pre-proposed i proposed and then
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and we got married
and then we were like all right then we
found we did everything kind of
backwards like we
then we moved in together oh i was
nervous about that
wow i would be too i was nervous because
that's a big no if i can live with
someone before like i
yeah lock it down legally until after
you married until we got engaged
i don't know i feel like if you made it
10 years now you don't have to deal with
all their [ __ ] habits like around
the house
that's when it gets weird that's when
yeah so you did notice
like did you notice some things like you
don't like about your wife when you had
don't let her watch this episode she's
gonna watch it no uh
well it's like little things right it's
like little things that i just
i'm like yeah it's a little annoying but
whatever sure like for instance
she never throws away the toilet the the
toilet roll
things i hate that same with steve oh my
god no the trash can is right there
put it in the trash right here but but
it's so small where it's like
yeah it's not a big deal but in my head
i'm like ooh
no we have one bathroom oh okay we have
separate bathrooms game changer yeah
yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] as well at the toothpaste at
the [ __ ]
toilet paper roll i don't have to deal
with any of that anymore
toothpaste that's another one she'll
like push in the middle like i'll roll
it up but
it's fine he leaves the cap off hmm so
you got to keep the cap on yo we got to
get that
dries up it's all crusty i'm like the
[ __ ] i can't stand when people
squeeze it and like wrinkle the whole
like the whole thing it's like a child
just squeezed the [ __ ] out of it and
it's all wrinkly and i'm like
oh my god and just flatten it out what
are you doing and then it's funny
because like you see that and then your
head you're like am i really going to be
about this right now it's like it really
comes out and she does the same thing
too like
some things will probably i'm sure we
haven't really talked about like hey
what annoys you about yeah
yeah you know but if we were to have the
conversation i'm sure it'd be very funny
um but she won't really i'm sure there's
i do things around the house that she
kind of gets annoyed by like sometimes
i met her i don't know since recently
i've been doing this but apparently
i don't close the cabinets all the way
closed
i'll leave it like a quarter of the way
and then i i walk back and i'm like yo
that is [ __ ] annoying like
like why do i do this well like instead
of closing the cabinet it will be like a
cracked opening
and i'll walk away and i'll look like
that's a really common thing that men do
yeah really yeah because there's like
this trend um that i was watching where
uh there's like that song that leave the
door open
and then like people are just leaving
all the cabinet doors and then
they're saying that that's like their
husbands because like a whole bunch of
dudes apparently do that
no that's a dude thing for sure i feel
like our cabinet's like it either
stays open or it's closed like there's
it like automatically closes off oh you
have a good cabinet you have one of
those ones yeah
yeah you need to upgrade your cabinet
the weighted cabinet doors or some [ __ ]
right
you know what's crazy though is so so
steve and i moved in together like three
months into our relationship
we've been together for almost it'll be
eight years this weekend wow
and i when we first moved in it was
completely different than now
i feel like i was so much messier like i
would leave a mess everywhere
i had to get annoyed by my own [ __ ] yeah
and then after i fixed my habits
then i started getting annoyed at his
habits because now i wasn't the messy
one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so it's like i feel hypocritical
because i'm like i used to be that way
but also like i got to change on my own
he didn't force me to change so i don't
want to be a nag
yeah so like i try to like just suggest
things
rather than like hey why don't you leave
your socks out again
yeah yeah yeah i think that's a good way
to do it right yeah
you never want to come in too hot if
you're coming too high
[Applause]
yeah like when we were going to marriage
counseling and all that like the
therapist would always be like okay hold
on like
use i statements like don't don't use
always and never and i'm like [ __ ] i
always say never
i never don't say never yeah yeah
exactly so then i'm like oh [ __ ] but
yeah she calls them soft starts
you have to enter like when you have an
issue with someone especially your
spouse you have to come in with a soft
start by
like starting with an i statement and
then cut like understanding what's an
example of an i statement
um like i feel frustrated when you
don't throw the toilet roll paper away
because it feels like it makes me feel
like you
don't care i don't know i'm really bad
at this i'm really bad at this
like i i feel because of you yeah see
that's why i'm not good at it
okay let's go like this because yeah
i've mastered thank you
i'm still working on it it's like um i
just
i get really stressed out when there's
clutter
um it would help me a lot to if if
you put things away after you use them
because um otherwise i i get thrown off
my my
way better you know something like that
where it's it's me that has the problem
and there's this activity that's
contributing but like
i it's my emotions because people aren't
responsible for your emotions or how
you're reacting to things so that's why
you're
taking responsibility for your own
emotions my wife does that sometimes
really i just realized my wife because
she therapizes me because she
i'm also starting to realize i'm like
did you just [ __ ] like do some
therapy [ __ ] something
like you just give me that casey
actually learned how to do it too really
well so i'm like oh [ __ ] like i
catch him when he's using a lot of the
techniques like the tools that yeah
that he has learned in therapy where i'm
like i'm so impressed
it helps yeah he is yeah what a dick
dude
outshine me you're out there yeah i know
you're trick you're better than me i
know you're [ __ ] no
dude i'm so thankful because if not then
we would if
if he was like i am now like how he has
been in the past then we would never get
anywhere in our relationship it's just
it would be a complete hot mess that's
dope but
speaking of hotness yeah what do you say
if you're not good at picking out your
own style don't worry stitch feel
it's just just filming stitch fix can
help you with that
they actually have everything that you
would get from a personal stylist but at
not the price point of a personal
stylist
much much lower what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go
online you're gonna fill out their quiz
which is just like they show you
pictures of different
outfits and you pick the ones that you
like and then from there they
will gather your custom style and put
together outfits
that are designed to fit your mommy
milkers
mommy milkers and they'll send you a
bunch of
items and what you're going to do is try
on pieces at home before you buy
then you keep what you love and return
what you don't love and stitch fix has
free shipping easy returns and
exchanges and a prepaid return envelope
is included there's no subscription
required
you can try stitch fix once or set up
automatic deliveries and you pay just a
20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards pieces you keep so if
the piece you're keeping is 30 bucks
minus the 20 styling fee you got that
for 10 dollars and you get a stylist
that you get to communicate with that
you stick with
and then you end up talking to them
having a communication of like hey i
really like this piece give me more of
this style yeah if you have like a
pattern coming up weddings traveling
maybe you're going over your personal
life you want a swimsuit maybe you want
more gym clothes
you can tell them request make certain
requests and they have a bunch of
different
um brands that they work with too so
um it's really cool they have quite a
selection and there are no hidden fees
ever stitch fix has styles and clothing
to fit any occasion for women men and
kids
they ship all over the us and available
in the uk as well mate
get started today at stitchfix.com mood
and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
mood for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix
stitchfix.com mood all right you fixed
your wardrobe now you gotta fix your
brain ball
we have talkspace here one of my most
favorite sponsors uh talkspace is the
number one online therapy platform that
has
thousands of licensed therapists trained
in over 40 specialties including
anxiety depression relationship issues
substance abuse
and more your therapist can help you set
and achieve your goals
it's also very affordable talk space is
a fraction of the cost
of in-person therapy instead of waiting
for an appointment you can
send unlimited messages to your
therapist 24 7
and they'll engage with you daily five
days a week which is true because like
uh what is it talk space is like a
what a couple hundred dollars a month
whereas one session i pay 450 dollars
yeah yeah wow so cheaper than a couple
hundreds
holy cow yeah so it's very affordable
and you can message them anytime any day
you have to wait a whole entire week to
talk to your therapist whatever you're
going through you can talk to them
or message them whenever you want and
they will respond five days a week
talkspace has thousands of licensed
therapists with years of experience you
get to choose which therapist
you want to work with it also shows all
of their um
degrees and all their accomplishments
that they have so you can specialties
their specialty
talkspace is also very secure and
private using the latest ends and
bank grade encryption technology to
store client information
as the listener of this podcast you'll
get a hundred dollars off your first
month with talkspace
to match with a licensed therapist today
go to talkspace.com
make sure to use this code mood to get a
hundred dollars
off your first month and show your
support for the show that's mood and
talkspace.com
for 100 doll hairs off your first month
that's
a lot of doll hairs
i have a question yes and if this is too
inappropriate you can be like [ __ ] shut
up
so i'm wondering because you're not like
um i'm not obviously not every guy's
like this but i would say a majority of
guys who have a higher
desire to like seek out other women do
you feel like you have a low sex
drive or no you just no
i think i'm able to compartmental not
compartmentalize it but like
do you think it's weird that i think
it's weird that that you've just no i
like
this in your whole life no i get it i'm
just to the total opposite
because i feel like that's rare right
like it is yeah i'm like dude you know i
didn't know that about you so now i'm
like whoa i want to put you under a
microscope maybe
how can we replicate it maybe there's
something wrong with my wife like maybe
she's
something wrong with her like that's why
she like me you know are you scared of
her
like in what way like in like i don't
know i feel like there's always like
a little bit of you gotta be a little
bit scared oh yeah
like so that she'll catch you oh yeah
well like even that stuff bro like i
just i'm not a
even if i were ever to be approached by
another
person and like you know like hey do you
want to do
i i'd kind of would feel [ __ ] weird
i'd be like yo like nah bro like it's
crazy
because also i've also been with my lady
for so long
yeah um you're just like used to that
not even just used to that but it's like
that's all you want yeah but also like
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what excuse me you don't smoke feed
other people sexually
especially once we got married like even
like even more so
yeah i'm just like i'm married bro like
what are you talking about
not really not okay no i think you're
just actually healthy
yeah and i'm like shocked by it
i'm like whoa you exist this steve is
just like that too
like yeah i feel like he's like a big
boy he wants to be married
he's also like the same kind of thing
like where
he looks in a crowd he's this is how
he's he described it to me was like
in a crowd like everyone is like the he
just sees girls but they're not like
they're not like a sexually attractive
to him until he like sees me and it's
like his inner
light lights up his loins his lines
light up
yeah that's what he says i think it's
also like your
your mindset too right it's like how you
kind of
think about certain things and i feel
like
since we got into a relationship i feel
like i've always taken that very
seriously
yeah you know like i'm always like nah
this is what we're doing like if we're
gonna do something
we're gonna do it like we're not gonna
[ __ ] around we're not yeah
like i remember there would be times
where people like you ask like oh like
do you guys go on breaks
sh there would be times where my lady
would be like oh we should go on a break
and i'd be like what the [ __ ] for yeah
like what are we doing like what's the
point of a break like
you tell me what the actual point of a
break is i don't agree with breaks yeah
like if we're gonna if we have a
disagreement
we should sit down and talk about it if
you feel like you really need to break
then you can
tell you need to break up and like at
any point i'm like
i say this now but you know obviously
who knows if this situation would ever
come but
if there was ever a point where my lady
was like look
you know i'm not in love with you
anymore like we can't do this [ __ ]
yeah it would [ __ ] hurt of course but
in my mind i'm like look
if you feel like this is not like you
see an absolute no future with each
other
then i yeah it is what it is that's so
healthy like if you if you that's how
you feel and i feel like she feels the
same way too yeah
i came to her and was like look i can't
do this anymore she'd be like
well [ __ ] i guess it sucks but like
you're not trapped no one's trapped like
you you're here because you want to be
here not cause like you have to be here
exactly and that's
what i'm like i don't know you feel more
freedom yeah even when i work with
clients like
yeah is it nice when people yeah like is
it nice when people want to pay you
money to train and work with them yes of
course
but if any point in time they feel like
this is weird or they don't want to
like they're just not into anymore dude
i totally get it like bro do your thing
yeah because you know it's everyone's at
a different place in their life at all
times
you know so it's like you don't want
what's not wanted exactly like if you
don't want to
hang out or do anything totally get it
you don't take that personally
yeah because it's like what's the point
i mean it will hurt but it's like
yeah all right well i don't want to be
with someone that doesn't want to be
with me you get those thoughts
everything
it's crazy for me to not think that like
of course you get those thoughts but at
the same time like you're able to
compartmentalize and look at it from a
different point of view to be like okay
well
i understand where this person is coming
from i understand how you feel but
if i i don't have to necessarily agree
with you either like yeah i could
disagree with how you feel about that
and that might bother some people to
certain extent and me too of course but
i think you're able just to be like okay
if this doesn't work out and it doesn't
work out
it is what it is no big deal like no
hard feelings has the passion stayed the
same
yeah yeah yeah dope like it's like it's
crazy like i never thought we'd ever be
in this position where
it's like we feel like we're more
attracted to each other yes so a lot of
people
would tell me stories like a lot of old
married couples would be like well after
you get married like
the sex dies i'm like i can't even
i'm just shocked like how many times in
your life have you heard of someone
that got with their high school
sweetheart 12 years later they're still
attracted and more more attractive yes
yeah like what the [ __ ] is happening
it's like impossible i didn't i didn't
know this about you and i'm just
mind blown i really do think like we
just got [ __ ] lucky yeah
yeah we're just one of those people that
just happened to find
10 million it does feel that way the
perfect combination of like
she knew what she wanted i knew what i
was yeah the timing yeah
and it just happened to be like we just
were attracted to each other like we
just couldn't
and you both were able to recognize it
at the same time too yeah which is
awesome
well it's i think it's just a perfect
storm of all those things right because
like all my buddies like they're they're
starting to
they're dating and they're kind of they
were single for a long time and they're
like yo i'm dating this chick but
like she does this and this and this and
that's like really annoying
and it's like all right i get it but
even when you're about to go in a
relationship you understand that
everybody has their own [ __ ] yeah
like everybody's we're all crazy in our
own ways you know
but the way you're crazy and the way i'm
crazy just
work together you know like it's
complimentary friends that are dating
are having a hard time i guess
realizing that i guess like there's
going to be
some give or take or like so they're
just not willing to come up with
anything i think some people
that maybe it might be a little younger
like my buddies are a little younger and
they can't really like they don't really
understand that like
it's more of a give and take like
because you're working with somebody
yeah that's what it really comes down to
it's an actual partnership yeah and it's
and you have to think about the long
game if you're not thinking about the
long game you're thinking about like tit
for tattoo for tat then it's like all
right then you might as might as well
[ __ ] break up like
that's why it all comes down to values
and life view
exactly like it really comes down to
that if you guys share the same values
and the
same view of how you think life should
go and you can work out the little
minutiae [ __ ] the rest is the details
the main principles that apply it's like
all right
religion is really important for a lot
of couples how you like politics is also
very important for how you
but i've see i have seen people kind of
have opposing views a certain degree
but the main points still stay the same
yeah yeah and but they agree on the same
points and
their top three priorities are in
alignment exactly
like i think that's very very important
that's so true because if
my my lady was very career driven and i
kind of was like yeah i'm cool with just
doing whatever
and there's nothing wrong with that yeah
but and if that's not what's
compliments her and supplements her
lifestyle and what she wants on a
partner
then it's probably not going to work
this man speaks the truth you know
it's not even that it's just like it
just just happens to work out that way i
have a question
um do you think that there are certain
white lies or things that you do to kind
of keep your
marriage as chill as it is
or do you feel like you're 100 honest
with your wife because sometimes i
wonder like
do i say too much do i speak my mind too
much when i'm in a relationship
like is there some glossing attacked
i know but i mean okay yeah i was i'm
going to say what nicki wasn't saying
it's the finesse of how you say it
yeah like because you don't hold
anything back but you'll just find the
best way to say it yeah like something
like for instance
me and my lady we were we were in a
fight yesterday kind of right so
i told her i was like i woke up in the
morning and it was like
seven o'clock and i was like hey i gotta
go i gotta go train somebody
then i have to go work at the coffee
shop and then i have to train with
somebody else at noon
and then i'll be like i'll be back at
like two o'clock or so
something and sh i wasn't home
for the past like three days like i've
been kind of working and stuff
so i was like all right i got home late
and we'll have dinner which is cool you
know
and then i left and then i i felt she
felt some type of way and i was like
ah [ __ ] i i kind of when i'm working i
just kind of forget about the other [ __ ]
i'm just like all right i got to do this
x y z and then i'll hang out with her
later like
that's how it goes right but her mind
she just was like you know she was kind
of upset
yeah she wants some quality time right
one of the love languages right time
yeah
so she was like kind of felt a little
annoyed yeah and i was like and as i was
training my client i was like
[ __ ] yeah i probably should clear
something out so we could like just hang
out like just get lunch or something
whatever
and then i hit her up and i was like hey
you want to get some lunch or whatever
and then she goes no it's fine like do
your thing like she if you want that i
was like oh
she's mad bro like i was like [ __ ] so
then i'm thinking about it and i was
like all right so i kept bugging her i
was like oh like let's go i cleared my
[ __ ] thing like let's just go get
lunch or let's just go get let's get
coffee or whatever the [ __ ]
and then she was like nah it's cool it's
cool cool it's cool i'm like nah it's
fine it's fine
and i come home and at around like two
o'clock and i was talking to her
and i know she's mad like i know like i
know the ups and downs and [ __ ]
and then she just like wouldn't talk
she's like i'm gonna take a nap and
she's just like doing her own thing
but in my head i'm like what the [ __ ]
like [ __ ] talk to me [ __ ]
like yeah like what are you doing like
if you're mad at me just [ __ ] tell me
like
in my head you're not letting me fix it
exactly yeah but i also know like this
is her process like
she kind of needs to come at it like
that yeah like i can't be like yo what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you you know like
in a perfect world yeah maybe but even
then it's like i probably wouldn't feel
the greatest if i did that you know
place it wouldn't work out
yeah yeah yeah i think you think more
outcome based like when you've been with
someone for a long time you think
you know how they react to things so
is is reacting like this to their
behavior gonna create the best outcome
exactly the long run and it's like that
with coaching right when i do nutrition
coaching with certain clients
like there are certain things that we
know you need to do right
and if you're not doing those things for
me to come at a client and be like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you you [ __ ]
idiot
like you didn't [ __ ] you went over
your calories like well you
how bad do you want it like if i were to
do that all the time i would have zero
[ __ ] clients
mm-hmm like nobody would who would talk
to you and then because you just kind of
waited out and then you're like all
right well
you know then you ask like probing
questions about like how does this make
you feel like
like you didn't hit this like what's uh
what happened
yeah how do you feel about being a piece
of advice yeah exactly like that is even
a better phrasing i'm going to use that
yeah
um but like that's
whatever's left but like that alone kind
of also taught me to be like oh yeah
like
there's no way you could just talk to
everybody like that no there's certain
people you can
i think that's what happens with couples
though is the more comfortable you get
with someone
the more harsh you like people become
because they get so comfortable
like you're the meanest to the people
that you care about the most that's
because you're just comfortable yeah
like letting that fly and you're like
well they're not going to go anywhere
so consciously like be aware of that and
to be like hey like we're a team like
we want this to be happy and like good
so flip it and be like well i should
nurture the people that
yeah i love the most like the
relationships that care most i care most
about
but that's so true because i definitely
fall into that where i'm like
i'm comfortable i'm not gonna put the
effort into
making sure you feel good because i know
you're you're still gonna be fine yeah
you're gonna let me know whatever
yeah yeah but that's so unhealthy yeah
well it's like
everyone kind of falls in that rhythm
you know like for instance like how i
haven't been really
probably been as present about spending
quality time but the fact that i'm able
to identify that and be like all right
how can i fix this
like i think that's really important so
that's the part where
i think when people see a happy marriage
like this where they're like wow
it's like that's goals like whatever
they think you guys it doesn't take work
no it takes work that's the work that it
takes is to consciously you're like
making little adjustments
all the time like being aware of how you
naturally emotionally react to something
and then
consciously changing the way that you
interact with the person
yeah and it's hard but it becomes this
rhythm and flow and so it gets
easier yeah but you do have to like work
at it
because i think the hardest thing for a
lot of people is just admitting when
they [ __ ] up
yeah you're pride aside like people i i
like i have a hard time with it too
sometimes like totally i'm not saying
i'm like the [ __ ]
the most humble ever nah [ __ ] that like
i'm a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] sometimes
we're all emotional in our own way we're
all people that's a better definition
like emotional creatures pieces of [ __ ]
yeah we're all scumbags in our own
[ __ ] way right
but at the same time it's like you got
to know when you
like to be what i get really upset with
and me and steve have conversations
about this when we're driving
because we have massive road rage oh
yeah it's scary
and i'm like you're going to get shot we
were on jk news and we were talking
about a road rage and me and
it was like me and steve just were
talking to each other and we're like
yeah and then this happens and then this
happens and we just everybody was just
like yo what's wrong with these guys
like these guys are [ __ ] nuts yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's where they let it
out
not in their marriage
low-key for a real and it's actually
been a problem i got a like did your
parents fight a lot and then that's why
you were like i don't want
yeah yeah yeah so that same so much
steve's always been like i never want to
take it out on you so i think you guys
take it out on the road your career is
you're like like fighting oh yeah i get
to i i get to do it through physical
activity and when i don't get to do that
i get really angsty and i get like
really snappy
like when i don't work out and i don't
train i get [ __ ] really angsty
so i'm able to realize like all right i
gotta train i gotta train it's good to
know
yeah right and um and so happens like
when i train and i get trained with my
buddies we get to just [ __ ] each other
up and it's like all good and it's like
all right cool
and we take it out you guys need to just
[ __ ] each other up kinda right
yeah it's [ __ ] weird testosterone
it's built up yeah yeah
but um but people just don't
really like they will fail to
acknowledge when they [ __ ] up
yeah and then it builds up over time and
then i look like even
just for my buddies like they'll tell me
stories i'll be like bro like you want
to know why she's [ __ ] mad it's
because you did this you [ __ ] jerk
off like you know what i mean that's a
good friend yeah
well it's also like it's it's a it's
very clear it's very like
not to them do you feel like you try to
help your friends a lot or do you kind
of just notice that they have a pattern
of shitty behavior and you just stay out
of it
only when i feel like all right they're
gonna listen they're bitching about it
oh yeah like when they are saying like
they're complaining about
this certain outcome that keeps
happening i'm like well this is the
reason why
and i'll just say it but usually i'm not
going to be like well actually you need
to be
i've been in a relationship for 10 years
yeah yeah like nobody likes that [ __ ]
guy either
so i only say it when unless i'm like
all right bro this is exactly what's
happening i'll give you the answer
yeah do you think the majority of your
friends should
get take your advice or like should like
listen to you more do you think that a
lot of them are floundering
uh in their dating lives for like one of
my friends yeah
one of my friends i'm like i think he
just needs to manage his expectations a
little bit
yeah because and he's just like
expecting someone that's like perfect
and i'm like
bro you're not going to get the perfect
girl i have no [ __ ] idea
i have no idea my wife's a leo oh yeah i
like leo girls you know gino's a leo
yeah [ __ ] i'm a i'm a libra
oh okay and apparently on paper balance
we match
yeah that's what it says so there you go
to the stars
yeah yeah stars you gotta get lucky
that's what actually helped us get
married
it was just like hey we're a match do
you have any cats oh really that's not
reason
you don't have any cats we have a bunch
of dogs well you should get some cats
let's go wow i [ __ ] fell for the bait
dude
i would love a cat though i'm starting
to like cats a lot high q recommend
so functional beauty it's the world
leader in fully
customized hair care i just washed my
hair with it last night yeah
me too shiny smells bomb i also use
their hair serum and
the leave-in conditioner and the body
wash and
the lotion body wash is incredible good
so they create your unique
formula based on a short but thorough
quiz to give your hair everything it
needs
to look and feel its best and like i
said not just your hair but your skin
too
every product is sulfate and paraben
free vegan
cruelty free and there are over 60 000
real five star customer reviews
and function of beauty fans are
absolutely wild about the fragrances and
for a good reason they're really good
your hair has never
smelled so amazing you can try tropical
mango sweet peach
crisp pear or subtler scents such as
lavender
rose and eucalyptus i personally love
the eucalyptus one rose
i'm on the peach right now if fragrance
is not for you that's okay
you can get unscented as well go to
functionofbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
on
off your first order that applies to
their full range of customized hair
skin and body part products that's
functionofbeauty.com
big mood to let them know you heard
about it here and to get
20 off your order functionofbeauty.com
big mood after you finish with the outer
of your
head maybe go into the inner and develop
some healthy
habits that may be contributing to
weight loss or physical goals as well
but it all starts psychologically and
noom gives you a way to
get healthy and stay healthy uh by
letting you know more about how you make
your decisions it gives you the
knowledge
tools and confidence to make strategic
choices that turn into long-term habits
which
you've been reading atomic habits right
yeah yeah and habits are everything
these incremental changes
that contribute to a long-term effect
over time
and those long-term habits turn into a
healthier happier
you so whatever your goals are if
they're weight loss if they're
anxiety if they're any some sort of
disorder that you're dealing with we're
going to examine
um what makes you what makes you do
those things what makes you
reach for a snack what makes you uh have
to go get a drink right away when you're
in a social situation
uh there's an ease in convenience to it
just 10 minutes a day and the tone of
the program
works with your lifestyle you don't have
to commit to a rigorous plan it's based
in psychology
it teaches you why you make the choices
you do using a cognitive behavioral
approach
meaning you're not just improving your
health you're gaining knowledge and the
habits you need to
stay healthy there's a science to
getting healthier it's called noom sign
up for your trial today at noom
noomnoom.com
big mood learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for your trial today at
noom
noom.com big mood ready to learn how to
live healthier sign up for noom today at
noom.com big mood
okay so you don't have cats you have
dogs we have dogs
you like have you thought about kids i
know everyone probably asked that
like 12 years together it's so funny
because a lot more of our buddies are
having kids yeah and they're just
popping them out and they're killing
them
pressured not pressured i think i think
i would like to have kids
yeah i would like to have kids 28. oh
okay
so we were like hey let's wait till like
we're 30 31 or something yeah yeah
and we'll just see we're having kids
later yeah people are living longer kind
of save up for that type of [ __ ] too
yeah just enjoy your youth a little bit
more too yeah we want to travel we want
to like we're starting to like
like seek out trips and doing stuff just
us you know so that's pretty cool
you know because i never for a while
that was never like an option
yeah you know well especially last year
yeah no one had that option
yeah we went to hawaii last year amazing
oh nice well they had the option
but that was great it was dope it was
like the only state that we could travel
to
that was like a vacation yeah for real
and it was empty like nobody was there
oh yeah florida
yeah that's where you spent your
honeymoon yeah yeah it was dope it was
really cool that's cool what island did
you go to we went to oahu
okay yeah we loved it so much we're
gonna go in october nice awesome
we saw tiff over there with david and
everybody and i was like [ __ ] we should
we're gonna go too then we're gonna go
oahu is great like for your first time
in hawaii and then
but kauai is like the most beautiful
place i've ever been to
it looks like jurassic park it does uh
it's got like this red dirt
everywhere like they don't really have
paved roads or at least they didn't when
i went like there was all red dirt roads
but it has this fragrance to it that's
like just
magical and the flowers and oh it's just
beautiful but
it's not like you know how on oahu
there's like the city
and then there's the beach um they don't
really have a city it's all like
countryside huh
yeah but it's like hiking and it's
helicopter rides and beautiful
waterfalls and all kinds of stuff but
it's very scenic it's magical
yeah very romantic yeah it's very
romantic but yeah we've been all
thinking about like all right now
where are we going to go before we
settle down and like have kids yeah like
we want to go to japan we want to do all
that stuff
do you like gambling no i don't okay i
do not like amazon i mean okay it's
healthy all across the board that's
great yeah
what's going on i don't drink i smoke a
little pop you know what i mean
but um herbs
um i remember my first time in vegas we
went out i was like i was 21
and we went for like a competition so we
were it was kind of like a work thing
but i went out there and my buddy was
like hey let's play craps and i was like
yes i [ __ ] love crap i've never
played crafts before and i was like all
right let's
he was like yo it's really dope it's
really easy
yeah he's like it's like your whole
group is the whole team yeah yeah so i i
threw the dice did it make it to the
back and i was like all right
and they were like looking at me like i
was a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
all right like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and i
was like all nervous and [ __ ] and then i
was like wait do i throw them now like i
was like freaking out everyone's looking
at me like come on like [ __ ] hurry up
uh and then i lost i lost like forty
dollars yeah a large
a large sum of money that's a lot and i
was sick to my stomach bro i like that
too
i couldn't eat it i hate losing money i
was like [ __ ] this you're not the right
energy for a crab stamina
get out of my craft stable i was killed
i was like get the [ __ ] out of here i
was like all right yeah yeah
the data yeah [ __ ] dude i ruined that
table um
everybody was so mad at me when i left
and i was like oh now i know what it's
really good though because then now
you're not losing thousands of dollars
or gaining thousands of dollars
see that's like
it's weird because sometimes when i see
people like i don't drink at all like if
i have a sip of alcohol i'm like my head
hurts and like i'm at a very fun time
like i've taken a shot sometimes and i'm
like oh yeah like it's cool but
usually i don't really like how long it
lasts you know um i'm a [ __ ]
cheap date like i'm lightweight me and
my wife shared a blue moon one time like
we drank half of it and i was like you
have to drive like i was like [ __ ] up
and i was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me
yeah it's [ __ ] so embarrassing is
your wife she drinks like she likes to
drink so she can call her whiskey tiff
because when she drinks she gets
because she's very like reserved but
when she started drinking last night she
had a couple drinks and she's like
saying wild [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
steve says that he cheats on me with
drunk nikki
yeah that's what he's playing right
completely different that's what he's
fun he's different too though
yeah he definitely is he's like
hilarious when he's
yeah and he like almost gets offended if
you like ask him but when he's really
drunk he's offended
and he's like no no i'm not [ __ ] good
like i'm [ __ ] good
stop asking him he'll say random things
where you're like nobody was talking
about that
that's how you know he's drunk yeah
like he'll be like yeah but in mars they
have space and you're like
oh yeah okay all right you're talking
about 90s
but then he'll say that with his back
turns against the the whole group
yeah and then like if everyone reacts
like what the [ __ ] he'll be like
no you don't get it you don't get it
you missed what i see oh she's [ __ ]
hilarious bro the more we've been doing
jk news i was like yo this is
he [ __ ] makes me giggle dude yeah he
says some [ __ ] that like i'm just like
i'm
i'm laughing like so hard everyone's
looking at me like i'm [ __ ] crazy you
know
but uh yeah like when i see other people
drink i do kind of get envious i'm like
[ __ ] like that looks like a lot of fun
when people smoke pot yeah i can't smoke
at all like i get hyper paranoid even
off like
half a hit yeah it's legal now so i can
talk about it
i'm very easily influenced so if
someone's like really high next to me
and i'm not high i'll start feeling like
i'm high yeah
i feel like you're ending with drunk
that's dope that's that's the thing
you're a really cheap date it's
transferable you know like it's tight
for one yeah that's that's when it's
really fun you can't be pregnant and
then you don't have to
you don't drink but you still get drunk
you don't have to spend money on weed or
alcohol you just kind of sit in the box
like i could remember what it felt like
and then i put myself in that state of
mind
yeah that's kind of what i do that's how
i get second hand sense memory almost
yeah
it's like that does it happen when you
get sick like when can someone get sick
when people get headaches i immediately
start feeling a headache dude that
happened recently jess was over drop off
her plants and she had
headaches like everything and then i i
never get headaches and i got a headache
after
yeah did you save your living room from
the headache energy
everything i feel like every time i
leave her house just to stage it because
i have a [ __ ] headache or
something oh yeah when you came over my
place you also had a crazy like i've
been having
headaches every single day i was
fighting it too i was just like no this
is about jesus
[ __ ] together it's not my fault but yeah
so it's crazy it's it's crazy how long
we've been together
that i think about it especially now
you're asking me more questions about
yeah all of it i'm like [ __ ] that is
kind of weird because i haven't really
sat down and really like thought about
it how many times a day do you think
that you think about your wife
uh a lot like she's on your mind all the
time because it's like especially when
it's a routine like all right what do we
got i gotta make sure
we kind of food what are we gonna do for
dinner that's like kind of daydreaming
do you ever just daydream about your
wife like think of her finally like
besides
like i gotta do this and we gotta do
that and we gotta do this
okay yeah yeah but like you know
sit there and think of her fondly yeah
and i smack her on the ass
okay okay i'm getting so
cute no i'm i'm insane for how cute i'm
making you be right now no no we do
i say [ __ ] very obscene things for
her all the time but do you think of her
fondly yeah
he does i think that's his version of
fondly
[Applause]
two different things what's the
difference okay no um
yeah definitely like i think [ __ ] i'm
trying to think like
what's your definition you just like
drive in your car and be like i [ __ ]
love my wife yeah yeah
you have to think about like oh she's
adorable when she makes mittens or
whatever
yeah yeah when she's knitting all the
time like i just wonder like do you guys
ever really do
i i think about how lucky i am to have
her a lot
i think about that i think i just needed
a dose of like cuteness from a man
yeah because i've just seen like so many
[ __ ]
in my life for so long i'm like do more
cute stuff nick yeah [ __ ] it
more cute see that's something i could
do more on yeah especially so my wife is
to be a little more cute because i think
i'm too like
she has experience you are oh she has
experiences yeah just like
i could be a little more romantic and
sometimes i'm like what the [ __ ] does
that mean to you
like but she can't give me an answer
book yeah you can figure it out no
you're for sure
but have you gina she's a leo but in my
mind i'm like i'm like but what does
that mean to you like what's your
audience yeah yeah you
right true you know you mentioned love
language earlier is her love language
quality of time quality time
time and quality time and i think uh
touch no not physical touch she's like
no she gets annoyed like she
gets annoyed because i'm very touchy i'm
always like hugging her she's like
please like today i give her a hug
before i left she's like your hands are
all cold
service yeah accessories yeah yeah yeah
actual service
so it's like little things like she
wants me to go take her to home depot
and get plants
and i was like you could have done that
yesterday but you were mad at me so we
have to go today
so we're gonna be doing that later today
yeah you know what i mean and uh but but
it's also like in my mind
that word like romantic like what does
that mean but sometimes she can't even
she can't even articulate
what that means to her hmm yeah that's
kind of true
because it is and if she were to ask
that to me i'd be like [ __ ] i don't know
did you do anything in the beginning
that was maybe a little more romantic
and
maybe she like wants a gesture like that
no
oh how was the proposal like what it
what was your proposal like
okay so we went to this place you're
real hard right yeah
it's it's it's gonna be it's gonna be
i'm like kind of nervous actually okay
jess is like looking off i'm like [ __ ]
uh first before you get into it did you
pick the
ring or did she kind of tell you what
kind of she kind of knew what style she
wanted okay and then i went on
a [ __ ] deep dive okay and then i like
that i learned about the diamond stuff
and then i completely forgot about all
of it
[Laughter]
i'm like [ __ ] i don't know like if i
could be [ __ ] cupid's acronym i don't
even know
um but yeah we i picked the diamond and
i got the cut that she liked
but the proposal yeah the proposal yeah
yeah so we went to point doom and i was
like hey let's go for a hike point doom
point doom is in malibu it's like this
okay
giant rock and there was a little like
deck
like overseeing that like on the side of
the [ __ ] mountain so then we went
there for a hike and we're
turning around and then she was like so
happened to like be looking off
into the water because there was like
whales it was actually kind of cool
and then she turned around i was on one
knee and i was like will you marry me
yeah
i'm still one of the boys on my right
guys
size four so that's a really small ring
so uh she she was she turned and she
looked at me she and
what she's and i asked was like will you
marry me she go and then her response
was
i can't believe you got on one knee like
that's what she said that's what you
said
and then and then she was like crying
and then i was like what are you crying
like just say yes and she said yes
what do you mean why is she like why are
you crying a little [ __ ]
yeah yeah so it sucked her a little bit
and that's the key to a sustainable
marriage
here we go but we're still you know
we're still like real young and we're
still like
in the midst of everything but i feel
like we were pretty
yeah i don't know we just have the
compatible personalities and i think
that's a big part of it
will you now reset how long you guys
have been together because i think
that's really weird
with couples yeah once they get married
that is when they start counting
how long like how long they've been
married but like for example casey and i
just had our nine year anniversary of
being together
but that was four years of being married
yeah but we didn't mention how long
we've been married so people were like
oh my god you guys got married nine
years ago when i was like
no we've been together for but i just
find it odd to like
the public expects you to to say your
marriage anniversary
yeah that's our fourth thing that's
weird to me where i'm like
i feel like you're erasing the whole
exactly i think yours together carries
more weight because i know a lot of
people that have been together for like
15 years
and then they got married and they have
the best relationships that i know of
the people that are like oh you've been
married for x amount of years like i
don't really know that many
i would never wait 15. it probably
started in like the 1950s where you got
married right out of high school
there was no like years of being
together before
marriage and so they just always used to
count it from there
married right yeah but then for you guys
do you guys count it from dating
from dating because i feel like that
carries a little more not
more weight your relationship into
perspective that's
that's the better way to say it no
especially since we moved in right away
like i feel like i've
lived with him for almost a decade so
like
to count it from four years ago is like
yeah that erases so much
exactly exactly yeah then like casey and
i we moved in at our six month mark of
being together and then it wasn't just
me and him like we moved in like with my
son like we'd be
yeah family and then to exactly to kind
of erase it
all to just start from four years ago
it's like no we've been married all this
time
yeah pretty much yeah no definitely and
um like for us like
we have our wedding anniversary and we
have our
relationship anniversary and it's like
more stuff to celebrate which is fun
yeah
yeah it's it's like we we could always
have more stuff to like oh yeah so we're
going to go out for this or we have
supposed plan trips for
our wedding anniversary or sentiment
yeah like
i think we are that's important too yeah
yeah like i'd never been with a
sentimental boyfriend
until steve yeah and we were both like
that and
did steve grow up with like like women
yes he mostly yeah and all my exes
there's a dating app that you need to
create yeah
because on the flip side on the flip
side too like my wife she grew up with
mostly like boy cousins
mm-hmm like like seven of them and he's
like beat her up like she knows how to
like
she knows how to be with boys yeah yeah
and i think that's important like
understanding how men are how they
communicate and understand how women
women communicate because like we could
sit here and talk about all we want but
it's like there are differences that's
exactly right because
yeah and for you to like negate that
it's like no bro like you have to
understand how
women communicate you understand how men
communicate like we're very different
that makes so much sense yeah because he
grew up with sisters i grew up with
brother
and boys and boy guy friends like all
right like for me as a guy i had to
learn how to like
be with guys yeah like i didn't learn
that until later in my life same with
women
yeah like all of us didn't have a girl
group up until like i was high school
like a lot of my
closest friends were female right and
then when i started when i started
training and i wanted to be a fighter
and i wanted to compete
and stuff and i would hang out with like
it's mostly all guys
that's when i learned how to have like
that male camaraderie
and that like learning how to be with
the boys
yeah just better to hang out with girls
or guys
i think it depends i think i think it's
literally
the people that you want to hang out
with because there's some dudes where
i'm like yo
shut the [ __ ] up and there's some women
that i'm like get the [ __ ] away from me
i don't want to spend any more time with
you
like it's all good like it's cool we're
not we're not going to be friends and
that's fine
yeah that's cool you know i mean like
that's cool so
i feel like you know understanding that
and knowing how you are
is really important too you know and
just kind of navigating all that stuff
because it can get really slippery you
know it's like it's yeah having certain
principles and having certain like
understanding hangouts with
the opposite sex no i don't really like
well all the
female friends that we have are like
really good friends of mine oh true
yeah and also too it's like their
boyfriends are really good friends with
with me or their husbands are really
more of a group yeah we were able to
kind of like this is my new favorite
thing about the pandemic was like we
were able to hang out with
group like friends of groups that yeah i
just never thought yeah and like now
we're like
like gabby she does a podcast she hangs
out with us all she was doing a paint
night
with my yeah with my wife like couple
and a couple of our friends
and they went painting and [ __ ] and they
were like oh we're gonna do all girls
night gonna go dancing in vegas
gaby was saying wild [ __ ] like i'm gonna
grind up on your girl on your wife and i
was like
i was like all right you believe you
believe daddy said that bro get
me going she's like no one's like right
at the end so i got
and i'm sure this [ __ ] does well thanks
for having me on i just thanks for
giving jess hope
yeah yeah like another glimmer of hope
that decent men
exist no you're about to move
you'll find it you're like there's only
a couple but good luck [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude dude there should be an app
like for getting vetted
like getting vetted by husbands oh yeah
yeah so like if the guy like a whole
group of husbands
you have to pass the panel yeah and then
they make it into the club
not just any husband yeah they have to
the husbands also have to meet a certain
caliber too
right true good people are good people
across the board that's it
yeah that's what you got to look out for
it's like it's literally just
you just have to have your values and
your life views and know what they are
and then know when you found that in
someone and the rest you can work
through
yeah and i guess as long as you put your
pride aside yeah you can work through it
i'm a firm believer that most people
just suck yo
i'm sorry like most people were just
like yeah come on here
but but there are a lot of people that
surprise you though that are just really
[ __ ] good and when you meet them i'm
always like
what's your [ __ ] angle dude yeah
they're just good people they're just
nice
you know like the first time i met david
you guys know david i used to be like
what the [ __ ] is your deal bro
yeah because he would be so nice and
he'd be so like helpful and like
be so cool like it wasn't for dave i
probably would have mentioned it
yeah like no he's just like such a good
guy and i used to always be like
what's like trust me yeah yeah like
there's something about you bro and i
just
and when i started hanging out with his
other friends like that's just how he
was like he's just a good genuine guy
so [ __ ] david so
[ __ ] david so go comment on davidson's
instagram yeah he said
that next the big movie we got beef
where can they find you you can find me
at nick the ear on instagram i need to
post more so you know you can find me
i don't i barely go comment yeah
but yeah you can find me on there on my
website nicktheyear.com yeah check out
our sponsors and subscribe and
uh thanks for listening thanks for
having me next time thank you for being
here
thank you thank you